Chanin's are different species of
ancient creatures that were once thought
to have gone extinct however it was
discovered that they survive by going
into hibernation subsisting on the
natural radiation from the Earth's core
they have been sighted throughout
history as evidenced by a variety of
cave paintings drawings and mythology
following Godzilla supposed death
tightens around the world started to
awaken from the slumber upon hearing the
call of Ghidorah the new Alpha Ghidorah
commands all the Titans to attack major
cities as a plan to terraform the planet
into a suitable habitat
however Godzilla manages to recover from
his wounds and he is able to kill
Ghidorah and becomes the new Alpha Titan
but the damage has been done and the
world today isn't the same anymore
everything on earth including humans and
natural ecosystems are in some way
affected by these titans monarch
believes that some of the Titans are
benevolent and necessary for the planets
survival and are the original and
rightful rulers of earth such as
Godzilla Matra and Kong however other
titles such as muta Prime Ronan and King
Ghidorah are considered destructive and
dangerous aside from the physical
destruction that they can cause without
being slightly hurt by attacks from the
military there is another important
component of the life cycle that he can
cause irreversible effects to humans
their radiation or rather the radiation
that they emit from their body it was
stated that in the movie that after the
2014 events which left the world in a
state of shock at all and the appearance
and destruction wrought by this gigantic
guide you the places that were in the
line of fire for example Las Vegas San
Francisco had a sudden and strong growth
of natural vegetation it was also stated
in the king of the monsters movie that
the radiation emitted by the Titans were
in fact helpful for the environment
so the question now stands if a Titan
radiation is harmful to us humans or is
it benign and has no effect at all first
of all let's take a look at what
radiation is
quickly into the matter in physics
radiation is described as the emissions
of energy as electromagnetic waves or as
moving subatomic particles
especially high-energy particles which
causes ionization this includes
electromagnetic radiation such as radio
waves microwaves infrared visible light
ultraviolet x-rays and gamma radiation
then there is the particle radiation
such as alpha radiation beta radiation
and neutron radiation which are
particles of nonzero rest energy
radiation is often categorized as either
ionizing or non ionizing depending on
the energy of the radiated particles
ionizing radiation carries more than 10
electron volts which is enough to ionize
atoms and molecules and break chemical
bonds this is an important distinction
due to the large difference in
harmfulness to living organisms so what
kind of radiation do these Titans have
and what kind of effects they have on
living things including humans and their
technology in the monster bus números
emit powerful
emps or electromagnetic pulses while the
emps have literally no effect on us our
technology which is electricity based is
often rendered useless and as we have
seen rodent and Mothra emit different
types of radiation with Rodan having
high thermal radiation and infrared
radiation since he was born of fire and
his type of radiation only affects
situations in that exact instant and
does not linger on Matra has another
different bioluminescence type that is
in fact helpful in healing and
regeneration don't believe me why else
were the ancient Chinese worship her and
build a temple around the moth and also
that her essence fell on to Godzilla
which enabled him to turn into burning
Godzilla
so other most of us titles including the
2014 mirrors also have these similar
radiation signatures that help nature to
revive and rejuvenate radiation from
tyrants like behemoth Methuselah and
Mikayla mbembe are helpful too for us to
regrow at a fast rate in the places that
they were in their hunting path but
their effects on plants might be
reversed in the case of animals and us
humans it might actually be ionizing and
sheeeit mutations in our cells but it is
still unknown and as yet undetermined as
we can see that there have been no
outbreaks of radiation poisoning nor
abnormalities in agents inside monarch
containment facilities including Carson
Bravo and these facilities contain
living dead and parts of dead Titans
even though these Titans search for
natural sources of radiation for food
and sometimes straying into nuclear
power plants and nuclear facilities
asked in the Muto's in 2014 and the
Kraken in the novelization the radiation
seemingly gets converted into a less
harmful type in their body then there's
Godzilla and his lair it was seen that a
nuclear radiation in his kingdom was
killing Serizawa but wasn't to the big G
an explosion actually healed him and
revitalized his strength
now with that amount in him it would
have Scott everyone on the return
submersible to death when he came out of
the water but it did not so it is safe
to say that a Titan somehow stow and
convert the absorbed energy into a less
harmful type and then radiated gradually
in order to maintain the natural order
of life but there's one form that is
alien and strange to this world the one
that radiates from master zero or at
least his decapitated head which is
still poisoning the fishes in the sea
near Isla Damona so if you have any more
information about this topic feel free
to share it in the comment section even
we are still much in the dark regarding
this anyway do like share subscribe for
more related content on most of us
middle-earth and more